it's been seven years since the release
of the last Star Ocean game but after
exceeding 30 hours buried in the
beautiful yet barren world of Star Ocean
integrity and faithlessness or Star
Ocean 5 it's difficult not to feel
disappointed its story and characters
are underdeveloped its mission design
fluctuates between uninteresting and
tedious and despite gratifyingly complex
combat and skill upgrade systems the
game is weighed down by a host of
frustrating smaller problem
I say I'm a perfectionist in Star Ocean
5 Fidel and his childhood friend Mickey
involved themselves in their home planet
Civil War and along the way discover a
bigger problem technologically advanced
beings from another world have arrived
and are using their home for nefarious
purposes along the way Fidel gathers a
ragtag band of not quite heroes to
rescue a mysterious little girl named
relia if we go with you then you may
never be able to return to this planet
again even if we do say Rio we might
never see our home again
unfortunately the narrative falls flat
characters are bland little to no
emotional development making it
difficult to care about their trials and
the plot does a poor job communicating
anyone's motivations there is a lot of
melodrama with no power behind it and
characters don't grow together and take
confusing emotional leaps the world of
Star Ocean 5 is big and beautiful but
feels just as empty as its characters
areas are vast and dungeons are
veritable mazes but none of it feels
alive enemy creatures spawn and clumps
in the same places every time making the
world predictable there's also no world
map and some areas are gated until you
progress far enough in the story making
the world feel small and defeating any
sense of exploration but everything is
better when you're in combat all
characters in your party fight at once
that you can only control one directly
at a time you can swap between
characters on the fly which comes in
handy during tougher boss battles where
you may want to oversee healing efforts
yourself battles are a flurry of motion
and light and are an absolute delight to
take part in even longer tougher boss
battles are welcome challenges and your
team dancing around the battlefield in
real time is a gorgeous display
that is if you properly develop and
assign combat roles and skills these are
unlocked by defeating enemies and
collecting special points which you
spend to upgrade roles and determine the
behavior of your characters in battle
you can unlock healing roles that
prioritize spells and assign them to one
character putting them in charge of
buffing the party and Dee buffing
enemies or you can give roles that
prioritize the use of special attacks to
your casters which ensures that keep out
of harm's way while still dealing the
highest amount of damage this creates
deep levels of customization within your
party and taking the time to unlock
develop and assign combat roles and
skills makes fighting a visual treat and
a breeze to navigate cooking up
assignments and strategies before major
boss battles is a highlight of my time
with Star Ocean 5
missions suffer from some odd issues too
many large-scale battles add much
unwelcome tower-defense and more
involved seemingly never-ending waves of
enemies with no direction for defeating
them still others pit you against
enemies you can deal no damage to until
dialogue leading up to the introduction
of a MacGuffin plays out these missions
are poorly designed and an abuse of your
time and resources side quests are
equally frustrating and very boring
although completing enough of them can
help you unlock specialty skills like
being able to see enemies on the map and
scavenging for resources but these
missions are nothing more than fetch
quests and not worth the effort it's
possible to never unlock certain
specialties because you never complete
enough or the right kind requests
Sargent 5 also suffers from a few weird
quirks characters constantly talk over
each other and too often while in a boss
battle or major conflict characters
would have conversations key to the plot
and I would be unable to hear them
pivotal conversations were lost to me
over the clash of swords and spells
I wish you the best sir
also Fidel can bump into and physically
move NPCs but we'll walk straight
through his teammates like their ghosts
it's incredibly jarring and pulls you
right out of the experience and Manuel
save points are infuriatingly few and
far between there are parts of the story
where the game actively blocks you from
saving between large battles and
unskipable cutscenesthat's is bloated
and empty with no worthwhile emotional
payoff and character development or
narrative combat and its subsequent
upgrade systems are genuinely fun but
the overall experience is held back from
being great by a lot of small things it
holds too tightly onto outdated
character tropes and concepts if you
came here searching for the epic sci-fi
glory of the series past this is not the
star ocean you are looking for
you